قال مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه ان محادثاته الاخيره مع القاده
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين تركته اكثر
قلقا بشان احتمالات تفاقم العنف بين
الجانبين كما قال خلال كلمه بجامعه
انه قلق ايضا من ان ما يحصل اليوم يحمل
الكثير من التشابه من الوقائع المرافقه
للانتفاضه الفلسطينيه الثانيه
في محادثات مع القاده الاسرائيليين
والفلسطينيين خرجت بانطباع جعلني اشعر
بقلق بالغ بشان احتمالات مزيد من العنف
بين الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين وقد كنت
دبلوماسيا كبيرا خلال الانتفاضه الثانيه
واشعر انا وزملائي في مجتمع الاستخبارات
بان كثيرا مما نراه اليوم يشبه للغايه ما
رايناه حينها وجزء من مسؤوليه وكاله
الاستخبارات المركزيه هو العمل بشكل وثيق
قدر الامكان مع كل من اجهزه الامن
الفلسطينيه واجهزه الامن الاسرائيليه
للحيلوله دون تفجر ذلك النوع من الع